[Music]
[Music]
here on this video we will explain 10
different life cycles of the xenomorph
life forms all are canon to the movie
timeline from the first alien movie to
the prometheus and alien covenant
prequels i bet most only know the
general egg to drone or queen xenocycle
but there are nine more including the
ones that brought about the neomorph and
the decon forms all starting from the
black goo
so let's get to this monster content
number one the common life cycle
the first one is the common one which we
all know by heart by now
first it starts with the queen xenomorph
and the specimen lays many eggs are also
called overmorphs from the egg comes the
face hugger which as the name suggests
wraps around a human's head and implants
a small embryo in the ears of vegas of
the victim
the embryo grows and bursts out of the
chest as a baby xenomorph called a chest
burster which then grows rapidly into a
mature xenomorph which could either be a
drone or a queen depending on the type
of face hugger
number two the hammer beat life cycle
this is a primal life cycle which is
very simple and doesn't really bring out
a xenomorph but rather a mutated form of
the hose creature it starts with a black
goo which is also known as chemical
a03959x.91-15
which is a highly mutated substance
pathogen
this black goo will either disintegrate
the body of an incompatible host such as
engineers as seen in the beginning of
prometheus and in the planet paradise of
alien covenant
while incompatible hosts are killed
outright the compatible ones are mutated
into highly aggressive monsters dubbed
as anathema or abominations such as in
the case of the small worms which become
the hammer p
number three the decon life cycle this
also starts with a black goo or chemical
a03959x.91-15
while direct exposure to large amounts
of it will either kill incompatible
hosts and mutate the ones that are
compatible a tiny dose of it if ingested
by male humans would then let it travel
to their reproductive system and then
the black goo will be transmitted into
the female human through sex and within
that a cephalopod-like organism will
develop called a trilobite the trilobite
here serves as some sort of a primordial
face hugger form which is many times
larger and if it gets to implant its
embryo inside an engineer then a weird
form of a xenomorph will eventually
burst out of the engineer and it will
develop into a slender but highly deadly
form called a deacon
number four the neomorph life cycle this
starts again with a black goo released
by the android called david on the
planet paradise life forms which mutate
the species into monstrous abominations
that die quickly and then the dead
bodies decompose and leave behind small
egg sacs which look like fungal spore
sacs
microscopic dust like spores called
moats are then released and when they
enter humans within a couple of hours
juvenile neomorphs would burst out of
the victim's body
unlike xenomorphs neomorphs have an
incredibly short lifespan and they
typically die within 24 hours of their
birth and fungus that interacts with the
corpse of a neomorph will be transformed
into new exacts
therefore restarting the life cycle
number five the praetor morph life cycle
yet another one that starts with the
black goo this one is kind of
speculative but it involves a dead
neo-morph like creature which the
android david experiments on to create a
bigger and a protoform of an overmorph
just like the normal x from the
classical life cycle a protoform of a
face hugger will then emerge from the
egg the difference is that this face
hugger's blood is less acidic and the
face hugger is also quite bigger
when the facehugger gets to implant its
embryo inside a human a chest burster
would then would eventually emerge from
the victim but this chest burster looks
like a miniature form of its mature
version unlike the classical xenomorph
chest burster which which slithers away
like a snake
the mature form is then called a
protomorph or a pareto morph
number six the original life cycle
i swear this is the last one that starts
with the black goo
and this involves the work of the space
jockey engineers rather than the android
david with hundreds of thousands of
years or maybe millions or even billions
of years of advanced technology behind
them the experimentation by the
engineers would obviously be more
sophisticated than david they of course
create the eggs or the overmorphs and
the original ones from akron or lv426 in
the first alien movie and so it's egg
then face hugger then human host and
finally the drone xenomorph the
classical one but this one is the
original
number 7 the newborn life cycle
this one includes the queen embryo that
was inside ripley's body for a long time
especially under stasis or also called
cryogenic sleep the long duration of the
queen chestburster being inside the body
of a female human being a ripley
inadvertently causes it to fuse and
ingest the female human dna
it getting a double y chromosome so when
the queen matures it retains its ability
to lay eggs but after a while it
develops a womb as said in the movie
alien resurrection ripley's give to the
xenomorphs the queen's womb
therefore not needing the hassle to make
overmorphs anymore the queen then gives
birth to a new xenomorph form called the
newborn which is by far the strongest of
them all and has a hybrid xenomorph
slash human appearance
number eight the drone reproductive life
cycle
ever wondered how the drones keep
multiplying in numbers without a queen
well in the anatomy of a drone xenomorph
which in itself is a topic for another
video that the drone has the ability to
lay one viable egg or overmoth obviously
the overmorphs laid by the drones are
small in the beginning it will then
eventually grow into a big one with a
face hugger inside of it
then we again come to the face hugger
then human hose then chest busted and
mature xenomorph part of the cycle the
only difference here is that the
overmorph the egg did not come from a
queen but from a lowly drone
number nine the egg morphing life cycle
this one is the most intriguing life
cycle in my opinion and definitely the
one that is the deadliest which also
explains how the xenomorphs manage to
multiply by the hundreds in a short
period of time in movies like avp
so the entire process is called
overmorphing which starts with the
absence of a hive a xenomorph drone will
begin taking holes and cocooning them in
a secreted resin that exposes them to
enzymes and growth hormones are from
their body that gradually shapes their
body the victim's body into that of an
overmorph the drone will then inject
genetic material from the bob of its
tail into the hose allowing it to
incubate as an embryo for a face hugger
and continuing the life cycle
this process generally takes 24 to 36
hours to complete and was originally
planned to be shown in the first alien
movie
and number 10 the drone mutation life
cycle this is the last one on this list
and definitely the one that explains it
all it starts with the classical
xenomorph life cycle but the most
important part here is that
if there is a drone and it senses the
lack of a queen for long periods of time
it will undergo a metamorphosis stage
where it will slowly evolve into another
form called the praetorian
and from that praetorian it will further
develop or mutate into a queen which
then has the ability to lay eggs and
continue the classical life cycle
this life cycle actually explains how
the queens came to be in the first place
and later on
in the future queens are developed from
royal face huggers
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam